[Music]
Patriots owner Robert Kraft is doing all
he can to help with cope with nineteen
relief look at this starting in April
the team's plane was sent to China to
bring back millions of mass for
Americans serving on the front lines the
fight against Cova 19 some of the mass
purchase by crap personally delivered
straight to the epicenter of the virus
to pop up the hospital at the Javits
Center in New York City he also sold his
prized Super Bowl fifty one ring for
over for over a million dollars as part
of coronavirus and a fundraiser he joins
us now the first of all beautiful ring
thanks for all you've done I'm going to
put up on the side of the screen all
you've done that's only a tip of the
iceberg the ring in particular that had
to be hard to give up they're not easily
obtained I know you have a lot of them
but no that one was pretty special in
you know I had a good friend Michael
Rubin who started the åland challenge
and he said try to come up with
something special they could garner a
lot of support and you know I thought
about our fifth Super Bowl when we were
down 28 to 3 with two minutes to go in
the third period and had a 0.04 chance
of winning the game 99.6 to lose and we
came back and it was a great great curry
and in some ways I feel the mood of our
country is a little down now and we're
still the greatest country in the world
we're going to come back and so I think
I thought that our ring epitomized that
and I'm happy to say that a a patriot
fan who wants to be anonymous right now
bought it but I hope will come public
with it mr. Kraft I've been pushing can
we open stadiums successfully I've
talked to the head of the Yankees I've
talked to so many different owners
people go through these turnstiles that
take temperatures if you want to go to
the game you got to wear a mask drink
your beer through a straw it's
inconvenient you do it for other people
it's proven safe in New York for those
that did this diligently your thoughts
well we very much we're preparing to
hopefully play football this while we're
working hand-in-hand with our union we
believe we're develop protocols that
allow us to do it in a safe way looking
out first you know for our players and
our personnel and then of course the
fans and how do we've we can do it okay
Tom Brady Belichick Brady and Kraft one
of the greatest trios in NFL history can
you comment on that
well I'm privileged have we in we just
we're about pleased God to start our
second century in the NFL I'm privileged
to have the greatest quarterback in the
history of the league in the first
hundred years and the greatest coach so
it's been a great joy to have this
partnership for 20 years
yeah always keep them together mr. Kraft
thank you for you doing your generosity
speaks volumes there's great Americans
like you that step up at a time of need
thank you sir